but it's not really my i don't think my
anxiety was it wasn't from the people
like i was uh
nervous to meet them i just go in these
waves where i'm
absolutely elated and no no anxiety and
just confident and want to make people
laugh
but there was a time period and i you
know and those scare you when you get
anxiety i don't know if you've dealt
with it but when you go through a period
of time where you're you're in anything
triggers anxiety and you're like am i
going to be
too tired am i going to be this or am i
not going to be enough i don't know what
it was but
there was a time period where i just i
couldn't even place where it was coming
from
do you get do you you know i notice you
you get cause you're like
i'm here i'm safe i'm in a completely
safe environment
i'm in completely control of
the time and and like the ratio of
you're in complete control yet you still
have anxiety which
that's a different anxiety i've had
anxiety when i when i realized i'm not
prepared
for a situation and then i get anxiety
maybe that's nerves what happens
to you oh you just yeah i mean there's
there's only been a couple times that
i've that i
feel like it's really gotten me but it's
like
it's just like you're outside of your
own head back here
um and you just
you're just out of it like you're just
you're not where you want to be and then
that creates more anxiety and then it
just like it compounds
yeah you're hyper aware of of all these
these these negative things you're
ruminating on all these negative things
which now appear to be real but they're
really not
but you're making them feel real right
yeah but the circumstances i'm talking
about where
i was not in control of the environment
um
whereas like what you're talking about
is interesting to me because
you know in that convention space you're
complete control yet
the anxiety is still crept in um
you know exactly but i think for me it's
always like my whole life i'm anxious to
make people
you know like me happy with me i want to
make you feel like okay rosenbaum's
always going to make me laugh
he's going to the energy is going to be
good we're going to get through the day
it's going to be more fun with him
around and i i feel like i i
i want to make you uh enjoy yourself
when
well exactly but i'm saying i think
there's a there's enough well i think
i've never felt enjoyment with you
what i'm saying is that i think that i
always want i'm a people pleaser i want
to make everybody happy i want to like i
want to
i always was like the fence the guy in
the middle that was i was watching the
bg's documentary which you should watch
you'll love it it just came out no i
just heard about this
fantastic but maurice was the middle gib
he was mid gib
and there were rob and gibb and barry
gibb on his brothers
and and you know they fought because
they were the best singers in the band
you know
robin was the guy or barry was like like
i'm waiting for this moment to last
you know and he would get the high and
the other but but together they were
enormous but they used to fight i i want
to be
i want to be the leader i want to be the
leader and maurice was the guy in the
middle
and so i'm like no no no he loves you
it's your brother he
no no no no that's not what he meant so
i was always like that as a kid with my
family you know your sister's a god dang
no no no she's your daughter peace
keeper peacekeeper and that
is exhausting i don't think you ever
wore you like i envy you because
in a lot of ways you uh i don't know if
you were innately born a leader i mean
look you you've you've got flaws you
like i know that you can be
short-tempered sometime you have you're
impatient like me
what what what you know and that's
and you're working on that jess is a
great wife because she also calls you
out on it and you're like oh yeah
yeah she's very quite grounding yeah
yeah does she does she ever say like tom
cause like
obviously i've seen therapy i i know
every actor i think ever does she ever
say tom maybe you should see someone
yeah she has yes she has
and what did you do did you say so well
there's someone that her and i both
talked to not at the same time and it's
been very helpful